what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four and the ending of this
video is going to be probably the most
important thing in this video and we'll
basically set the stage for like one of
the most epic moments ever in the
history of Marvel Comics but what this
does here is this initially opens up
with a Fantastic Four basically facing
off against Bentley Whitman also known
as wizard now here's the thing Wizard's
basically a guy who's super intelligent
with regards to this particular bit of
the story it's not overly important but
anybody who knows anything about
Jonathan Hickman knows everything he
does does become important somewhere
along the line so while the wizard I
will say he's defeated pretty easily
right I mean this is literally like
three or four pages it's just not overly
important while the wizard is defeated
one of the things the Fantastic Four
learn is that the wizard had actually
been creating clones of himself now as a
super intelligent guy the wizard
initially made his bones by just
developing incredibly advanced
technology and then just selling it off
to the rich and the powerful and then
just became incredibly Rich because of
that but then he ultimately ended up
becoming a criminal and he just joined
the fight for four and face off against
the Fantastic Four in the old Stanley
Jack Kirby Days and he's never really
been a major villain in the Marvel
Comics universe but the thing about this
is that one of the things that he had
done is he actually created one of the
more newer clones which is a child
version of himself named bentley23 and
so in the face of the fact that he had
basically been cloning himself and the
face of the fact that like this little
kid is here what they end up doing is
following his defeat they actually adopt
Bentley 23 or just kind of bring him
into the fold but following that one of
the things that happens here is you have
this discussion between Reed and Susan
where when it comes to Susan storm one
of the things to know as far as Reed
goes his intelligence is one of those
things where he's always kind of removed
from everything that's going on right
he's there but he's not there right he's
present but he's always thinking about a
million other things now the
relationship between Reed and his family
is probably the single most important
part of this video that we're talking
about outside of the ending of this
video and the reason for that is because
if you you guys recall the video that we
did on basically the dark range story
that Reed Richards had come to this
realization that in order for the earth
to become a better place right when you
look at all these different alternate
realities where Civil War had happened
the formation of the Illuminati all that
kind of stuff secret Invasion and so on
and so forth he came to the realization
that in all these alternate realities
where things turned out peacefully it
was because he only ever did things on
his own that he didn't invoke the
Illuminati that he was never part of
Civil War just things along those lines
and so as a result of that Reed had come
to the conclusion that he needed to
solve the problem of everything but
during that story he had constructed the
bridge which is what allowed him to see
an alternate realities in the first
place and was ultimately met by the
arrival of just these disembodied people
who simply said like we will be here
when you're ready and so ultimately
redoes exactly that he literally opens
the bridge contacts these people only to
find out their alternate reality
versions of him and so bringing him in
right when he basically follows because
he's curious to see what this is all
about he's basically taken to a place
called The Citadel which houses a group
known as the Council of Reed now one of
the cool things about this and the way
that this is explained to us that this
Council of reads is composed of a
variety of Reed Richards from alternate
realities and they differ in a variety
of different ways for example one of
these Reed Richards looks like he's
basically Xavier from an alternate
universe meaning he's probably a mutant
and he has the ability of telepathy so
on and so forth there's some versions of
Reed Richards have the power of the
Silver Surfer that other versions of
Reed Richards the powers were shifted so
instead of Johnny's storm becoming the
Human Torch it was Reid who became the
Human Torch instead now there is going
to be a much darker component to this
Council of reads in a few different ways
but before any major questions are
answered what ends up happening is
there's basically what's referred to as
a Galactus incursion meaning Galactus
has arrived on Earth in an alternate
reality with the intention of consuming
it and so one of the things that Reid
learns when he's brought into this
council is that it was created by one
guy but there's actually two other
versions of Reed that rule alongside him
that these three versions of Reed
Richards all have an Infinity Gauntlet
now one of the things that's basically
given to us here is that The Infinity
Gauntlet is more ceremonial than
anything else and it's basically
designed to show their place and as far
as ranks go among the Council of reads
that they're the leader of the council
and the reason for this is because back
in the 1990s and it's really solidified
here by Jonathan Hickman that you had an
Infinity Gauntlet that basically arrived
in the DC Universe but it didn't work
and that basically established the idea
that the infinity gauntlets only work in
their native universe but the the
important thing here is that in this
alternate reality one of the things that
happens when when the Council of reads
emerge here is that unlike Galactus in
the main Marvel Universe where he has
one Herald this Galactus actually has an
army of Heralds there's multiple
versions of the Silver Surfer and this
is kind of a cool thing because of
course they basically end up defeating
this alternate reality version of
Galactus it happens off panel we don't
actually see it take place but we're
basically told that's what happened and
so when Reed joins the Council of reads
again the next day kind of again hitting
it this guy idea that he's just sort of
removed from his family he's there but
he's not there like they're having
conversations they're talking to him but
he's kind of like this is the thing that
we end up picking up basically in
Universe 8901 now the funny thing about
this is that this is a world that's
being used to create food and that he's
being introduced to This World by the
council to show them the breadth of
things now the funny thing here is that
Reed looks at this and is like this is
awesome right because you're literally
growing food on a world in order to feed
other worlds in this galaxy and the
response that this alternate read gives
him is this is the problem read you're
thinking too small you're thinking on a
small scale we as the Council of reads
operate on a multiversal level our
Citadel is outside of space and time
which means that our purpose is on a
much grander scale think bigger this is
a universe that is largely devoid of
normal sentient life so in this universe
we don't just grow food on this one
world I've got hundreds of Worlds where
I do this and we literally bring these
resources to other worlds across the
Multiverse we just bring it all over the
place to Worlds that do have life in
this universe but are struggling to make
it and other places across the
Multiverse and there's entire universes
that I have like this my entire universe
is where all we do is grow crops and
feed other universes in the Multiverse
and that's one of the cool things about
the council is it's utilizing the full
capabilities of Reed Richards thinking
on a massive scale a much grander scale
and it's one of those things where
Jonathan Hickman writes this in a way to
where while Reed is incredibly
intelligent he is limited by his
experiences living among normal people
in a singular Universe the average
person is not nearly as smart as Reed
and the average person isn't really
capable of thinking about things outside
of themselves in any one particular
world right like this thing is a major
issue and I feel that way because it
affects me on a personal level if it
doesn't affect me on a personal level I
wouldn't give it as much attention as I
would to something that does affect me
on a personal level whether it's selfish
is outside of this discussion that's
just simply how it is but for for
somebody like Reed who is capable of
thinking outside the box this is the end
result this is what you find people
building food sources on whole worlds
and feeding the Multiverse now one of
the darker elements of the Council of
read happens on the third day when one
of the reads is like you've seen the
farm right and the response of Reed is
yes and so this guy says it's important
that you saw that so you can understand
the significance of what we do here
everything we do has a purpose and what
they're doing here is they're actually
facing off against a Doctor Doom in an
alternate universe and one of the things
that they do is they basically grab an
inhibitor collar once they hold them
down they grab an inhibitor collar and
Doctor Doom's just like do your worst
I'm never going to stop right now one of
the things to know is again this is an
alternate universe Doctor Doom this is
not Doctor Doom from the main Marvel
Universe but the whole reason why Reed
was shown the farm before he was shown
this is because this is one of the dark
realities of the Council of reeds that
in truth what they came to realize is
that Dr Doom's quest for power is in
insatiable he will go to any limits in
order to attain absolute power that in a
lot of ways he's even worse than
Galactus Galactus does what he does and
he wipes out whole world because it's
his role in the universe for Dr Doom
it's just about acquiring power and
that's one of the things that they
realized is that at the end of the day
he literally wants nothing more than
absolute power and so in any one
Universe Dr Doom is literally the most
dangerous villain there and so what the
council does whenever they come across a
version of Doom that makes his move and
starts trying to acquire absolute power
is they lobotomize him and then when
they do that they stick him below a
council they stick him in What's called
the hole right this place this deep
below the council chamber and all these
Dooms just stand there that's all they
do right they can't think they can't do
any of that stuff and so that's kind of
a really really dark element of the
council but one of the other things they
do here and this is one of the cooler
elements is outside of like providing
food and resources for universes or
worlds that may not have them they also
play another part of their humanitarian
effort and the sense so what they do is
actually save worlds from destruction in
this particular instance what they do is
use their technology to enter into a
universe and then grow to a colossal
scale bigger than a star and literally
perform surgery on this star because
it's about to go supernova and that
removing this piece of matter that's
going to lead to the collapse of this
star making it go supernova and then
converting into a black hole and wiping
out all life around it is they've
literally saved an entire solar system
they saved a whole star system but
that's what they do here right that's
literally the things that they do is
they work on saving the lives of other
people who are out there other realities
any number of things however as awesome
as the council is everything goes belly
up because what ends up happening is as
they're in the council right just kind
of doing their thing and they're talking
and so on and so forth that essentially
there is an incursion right the Gateway
is breached and like the council itself
is compromised and their whole stance is
what in the hell happened right like
like what's going like what if Force
could possibly in like invade the
entirety of the council and that's when
you and up finding out that what had
happened is there was a version of read
here in the council that traveled to an
alternate reality and what he had done
is that he had realized in that
alternate reality the celestials had
gone crazy the celestials had lost their
minds and basically started fancying
themselves gods and presumably wiped out
any Cosmic entities that stood in their
way and then started forcing the
denizens of that Universe to worship
them as Gods but when this alternate
reality version of Reed went there his
belief is that he could destroy them he
could defeat them and free that Universe
from their yoke of Oppression the entire
opposite happened Instead This alternate
reality version of read was taken by the
celestials by The Mad celestials his
mind was quote unquote torn open meaning
they basically forced their way into his
mind and started reading all of his
thoughts learned about the Council of
reeds and that in doing so came to this
realization if they can invade the
Council of reeds and then steal their
technology their ability to enter in and
out of alternate realities that these
mad celestials can take over the
Multiverse and so they do a exactly that
they arrive here and just start killing
everybody right all but one of the
leaders from the Council of reeds are
destroyed so one of the things we learn
here is that one of these reads is the
has the ability to open portals to other
realities just by the nature of his body
and the truth about this is that one of
the the surviving leader of the council
with an Infinity Gauntlet is like we
need you right the reality here is that
this read this portal read his body will
burn out it won't be able to handle the
strain of being used as a vector for an
Infinity Gauntlet but nonetheless the
alternative is that all the reeds are
destroyed in the council and so what the
leader does or at least the remaining
leader is with The Infinity Gauntlet on
one hand he reaches through the portal
which establishes him as existing in the
reality where The Infinity Gauntlet came
from it's one of those things as long as
you have one hand in that Universe you
can use The Infinity Gauntlet and in
doing so uses the power of the gauntlet
to destroy one of the celestials now
there are others who are there and this
is one of the things to know is that
when it comes to what's happening here
it's all happening so fast that even the
power of the gauntlet is limited because
when it comes to The Infinity Gauntlet
yes you can alter reality on a cosmic
scale but all this is doing is basically
allowing this version of read to channel
the power of The Infinity Gauntlet in
the form of like concussive blast but
the reality as it exists here is not the
reality The Infinity Gauntlet comes from
so you can't like turn the celestial
into something else but you can't just
like whisk it away or wipe it out of
existence or anything along those lines
because they're not in the universe that
that Infinity Gauntlet comes from does
that make sense I hope it does because
it's the best way I know how to explain
it but what ends up happening is the
main Marvel Universe read takes off to
his own universe and ends up basically
grabbing a whole bunch of arms and
Armament and then bringing them back to
the council and that when they have
those weapons they're able to basically
use them to annihilate uh some of the
Mad celestials not all of them but
basically Force the Mad celestials to
flee right to literally take off back to
their alternate reality for fear of
being completely destroyed and so with
the the immediate threat basically
baited the version of read whose mind
was taken by the celestials he
establishes to the main Marvel Universe
read that now he's lost his his
intelligence he's not nearly as smart as
he used to be and that's when the main
Marvel Universe read is like look man we
can take you back to my reality and we
can fix you right we can make you better
and and the response of this alternate
read is but like what if you can't
because nothing is more important than
my intelligence and that's when you
learn really the darkest truth of the
Council of reads because the main Marvel
Universe read is like what are you
talking about right you have your wife
you have your kids and that's when this
alternate reality read is like no we
don't that's the price we pay for
forming the Council of reads we left our
families behind the reality here is that
solving the problem of everything Reed
requires absolute focus and so what
happened with each of us is in joining
the council our attention was taken away
from our families and focused on here we
didn't necessarily abandon them in the
most tried and true sense in the in in
the form of the fact that like we joined
the council and they just never saw us
again the truth about this is that as
Time progressed Susan storm in each of
our realities got frustrated because she
was raising the family on her own that
our sons and our daughters Franklin and
Valeria they began to learn to hate us
because we were absentee fathers that
our friends Johnny Storm Ben Grimm they
turned their backs on us because we were
never there for them the truth is that
we were there with our families but we
weren't there we were always basically
just ignoring them because we were
focusing on other things and feeling
abandoned and alone in each of their own
ways they turned their backs on us so we
did the only thing that we felt we could
do in that circumstance instead of
basically making amends with our
families we ended up joining the council
full-time and that's when the main
Marvel Universe read is like that's
never gonna happen I am not doing that
with my family now that right there is
the single most important decision that
Reid Richards makes over the course of
the story I want you to remember that I
want you to remember that singular
decision where he refuses to turn his
back on his family because that is the
entire basis behind Hickman's Fantastic
Four that's the whole basis behind it
everything that happens over the course
of this story all the good good and all
the bad and the really bad that all
happens because of that decision that
Reed made not to abandon his family it's
the single most important thing and so
ultimately Reid walks away and this
alternate read is like you're gonna come
back man like it's going to happen that
you're not going to stay gone you're
absolutely going to come back here and
so what this does is it actually jumps
to a flashback between Reed Richards and
his father Nathaniel Richards who and
depending on what reality you're talking
about Nathaniel Richards will actually
go on to become king the Conqueror this
particular Nathaniel Richards he doesn't
but it is one of those cool things one
of the things that I also want to
establish is that Nathaniel Richards is
going to become incredibly important to
this story as time goes on but the
reality here is that for reasons that
weren't initially explained to read
Nathaniel was not always there Nathaniel
was not always a main part of his
character instead what ended up
happening is Nathaniel was always just
kind of there and not there right he was
in a lot of ways the version of read or
those different versions of read from
the council that were there but just
sort of absent antique and so there
comes a point when he visits Reed and
says like I have to leave right like I
have to go I don't know when I'll be
back I don't even know if I will be back
and where Reed wants his father to stay
the response of Nathaniel is I've taught
you everything that you need to know
what I've taught you everything to to
make you a great person and this is the
influence on Reed that led him to make
the decision that he did in abandoning
the council because what his father told
him when he was young is you have a gift
read you are and potentially will be the
smartest man in the world but having all
that intelligence is useless if you
don't have a heart to go with it because
the ability to empathize with people the
ability to look at another human being
and to say even if I haven't necessarily
lived your life and I cannot experience
your actual emotions I can understand
the pain that you're going through and I
have a desire to help you through it
that's what will make you great that's
what will differentiate you between a
hero and a villain so keep that do not
lose that never ever ever lose your
ability to care right I want you to
become a better man than I ever was and
I want you to become a better father and
the result of this is that Reed
basically ends up walking away from the
council and rejoining Susan storm who
was literally on the verge of feeling
that Reed just doesn't care that Regis
doesn't want to have anything to do with
him that they don't really matter to him
right he was Reed pulling himself back
now what this does is this switches over
to the birthday party of Franklin
Richards now for those of you guys who
are very familiar with Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four you'll notice
that we're skipping over this segment
with Ted Castle the reality here is that
in order to make that make sense we need
to cover the Mark Miller Story with with
Ted castle and all that before we
covered that particular segment here it
was something that I realized not too
long ago but the birthday party of
Franklin Richards is the most important
thing that we are covering in this video
and here's the reason why so again it's
Franklin's birthday and everybody's
having a rip roaring good time right
like it's not just it's not the birthday
party that we're focusing on don't worry
although it is cool but it's like it's
the cutest thing ever right like
Franklin's having a great time you know
they're celebrating everything and in
fact it's one of those situations where
like they like Ben Grim's like hey guys
I have a special guest for you and
they're like who's that and he's like
it's Spider-Man and it's obviously some
guy who's not Spider-Man and like all
the kids are like that's not Spider-Man
and then Ben Graham's like well that's
weird I could have sworn I saw him
around here somewhere and like
Spider-Man's like hanging on the back of
Ben Grimm and the kids are like that's
Spider-Man it's a blast right it's just
an absolute like just amazing time and
so as a gift to Franklin Richards and
this is one of the things that I want
you guys to keep in mind as a gift of
Franklin Richards uh Peter Parker
basically takes Franklin on uh on a trip
around the city now we don't really see
the trip taking place it is kind of a
cool thing that whole situation will be
stupendously important the relationship
between Peter Parker and Franklin
Richards that's gonna be astronomically
important later on down the line but
that's not the important thing that
we're talking about here instead like
all the kids are filling up on cake and
and everybody's just having an amazing
time but the Knight ultimately begins to
wind down right everything begins to
come to a close and all that kind of
stuff and what it does is it switches
over to later on that night right and
then there's an alert that comes in on
the security system time Quake condition
red somebody's coming in through the
time stream right this person emerges
and it's just like containment field is
activated and the clock is running and
as expected Here Comes company right the
Fantastic Four immediately respond now
as soon as they get up here they can't
pass through this guy's barrier now this
is one of the important things that I
want to establish here the fact that the
Fantastic Four cannot get past this guy
is a huge deal because Susan storm is
the queen of force fields and you're
gonna see how powerful her Force feels
are by the time we get to the end of the
story because people sleep on how
powerful Susan storm is they don't
realize how powerful this chick is she's
a monster right just an absolute demon
on Power and so this guy literally shows
up here and Franklin comes wandering out
right Franklin Richards just comes
wandering out of his room and this guy a
immediately seizes Franklin and the
Fantastic Four like what in the hell
right this guy lifts Franklin into the
air says something to him and then
Franklin just passes out and then
following that he goes into the bedroom
of Valeria now here's the thing what he
tells Valeria this is incredibly
important because this sets the stage
for all the stuff we're going to be
talking about next over the course of
this run right when this person's when
Valeria is like who are you this guy's
like I was sent to find you right and to
give you a warning that the future must
be avoided at all costs and he says
listen closely because each word I say
was chosen carefully it is just for you
Valerie no one else can know this there
will be a war between the four cities
the dead must not be forgotten the
future man must return to save the past
and all hope lies in Doctor Doom and so
this girl's like why should I believe
you and the response is because you are
the one who sent me here and so
following that this guy teleports away
now with that whole situation unfolding
with this man just being here and then
disappearing everything kind of goes
back to normal readers analyze everybody
he's studied everybody there's no real
effects or anything like that not that
they're aware of but the reality here is
Reed has no idea what was done because
what we do is we transition back to the
room of Franklin Richards and this guy
literally when he sees control of
Franklin said rust and remember what you
are and this little kid this God kid
this kid that has the ability to
virtually alter reality on a universal
scale where his powers have spent all
these years being shut down and blocked
by Reed Richards or woken up Franklin
Richards now has the ability to alter
reality on a universal scale and you are
going to find out just how far reaching
these powers are and just how stupidly
broken Franklin Richards is by the time
we get to the end of Jonathan Hickman's
run with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later peace